the amazon rainforest is often referred
to as the lungs of the planet it's a
huge carbon sink of course which means
that it absorbs more carbon dioxide than
it emits so helping keep the global
temperature rise down
but as we've heard the amazon is being
destroyed at ever increasing rates
leading to reports that it's close to a
tipping point i.e emitting more carbon
than it absorbs so are we too reliant on
the amazon so let's
put this question to you richard and
we're used to hearing of the amazon
rainforest as the world's most important
carbon sink so how worrying do you find
these reports of record illegal
deforestation
what will happen to climate change if we
do see the amazon starting to emit more
carbon dioxide than it absorbs
i think it is very worrying i mean the
great the three great rainforests of the
world the amazon the congo and in
indonesia borneo and so on um you know
have absorbed about you know a quarter
of the carbon that we've put into the
atmosphere but we know that that is
weakening it declined by something like
a third over the 30 years from from 1990
um there was a report out earlier this
year showing that in a part of the
amazon has changed from being a net
carbon absorber to a net carbon emitter
and there's a lot of science around over
the last 10 years showing that you could
get to a state where the amazon
basically goes from being a forest to
being a savannah so anything that
increases the risks of that happening i
think it'll be taken very seriously and
one thing that i picked up from your
report that is absolutely true is that
this is not an accident that this is
happening under jaya bolsonaro his
philosophy is that
uh that environmentalists and indigenous
people who oppose this kind of
development are somehow
anti-brazil it's
anti-brazil's economic development and
um it's no surprise i i did a little
police analysis a couple of years ago
and we saw lots of forest fires breaking
out in the summer and you were seeing a
much bigger increase in forest fires in
provinces that were governed by
bolsonaro allies than in other provinces
and cece do we rely too much on the
amazon as a carbon sink are there
alternatives out there are there other
parts of the world where trees can be
planted and we can stop worrying so much
about the amazon
yeah um the amazon is really really
important so you know we must do
everything possible to protect it but
you are right i think um you know we
there are things that we can actually do
and one thing is by planting tree and a
study has actually shown that if we grow
uh 1 million trees we have the potential
to keep global temperature rises to be
below 1.5 degrees and so this really um
you know is a very uh hopeful in a way
so i have right good news actually so
the earth is now actually greener than
20 years ago and that's largely because
we have uh grown a lot more trees and
india and china have actually grown
enough trees to an area which is the
equivalent of the amazon forest um so i
think this is really strong evidence to
show that we as human beings we are
capable of change we can change we can
do stuff together if we want to and um
i'm i'm yeah
i'm i'm just hopeful that we'll do stuff
together to solve the climate prices
it's always good to end on the word
hopeful we will leave it there dr cece
who richard black always good to see you
both thanks very much indeed